[Music]
foreign
American medical tourism might sound
like a trip to Mexico for a bbo or Costa
Rica for rhinoplasty well America has
its own corner of the medical tourism
Market which in 2021 was valued at 4
billion dollars and is expected to
increase substantially over the next few
years so much so that between 2022 and
2030 America's medical tourism sector is
projected to increase nearly 33 percent
and the money doesn't just come in from
treatments alone foreign patients need
to consider additional costs that
include airfare housing food Outpatient
Care exchange rates and more all which
funnel into the operating systems
economy one of America's most popular
cities for medical tourists Houston
Texas Houston is an international
Healthcare destination for patients
looking to undergo a variety of
procedures ranging from cosmetic to
life-saving Cancer Care and is home to
one of the largest medical districts in
the world
went to Texas to understand how medical
tourism impacts the city's economy with
help from in-state experts who know the
system inside and out including Dr
vaquis founder and director of the
center for medical tourism research
medical tourism is basically Health
seeking behaviors that go beyond
traditional boundaries and borders this
could be people that are traveling
outside of their city county or even
state or potentially even outside the
country to get access to care that they
want at the price they want at the time
they want at the location they want and
at the Quality they want medical tourism
the nomenclature of medical tourism is
an interesting term but it turns out
it's very appropriate the reason I say
that is that when people are traveling
for Health Care particularly over a
border whether that's a domestic or an
international border they tend to engage
in tourism so for example here in
Houston the Texas Medical Center is the
largest Medical Center in the world
receives a lot of international patients
from all over the world primarily places
like Asia Latin America and the Middle
East and when people come to Houston
they engage in tourism our studies find
that about 70 percent of the medical
tourists as we like to call them that
come in for various types of care will
also engage in some tourism in terms of
going to a local festival or concert
my path into medical tourism and
researching medical tourism is that when
I dropped out of Industry I was a
hospital executive for one of the
largest publicly traded Hospital chains
in in the world and I came over to
Academia there was really nobody else
studying medical tourism at the time
they had a focus on it and so I was
really interested in it because the the
whole idea of patient consumerization
people taking control and responsibility
for their health care and then going out
and finding the health care that they
want and in fact being able to find
Alternatives from the traditional models
of Health Care that they were being
offered in the United States and around
the world was very intriguing to me I
started reporting on medical tourism
because of that story back in I think it
was March of those four Americans who
went down to the uh to Mexico and they
were kidnapped in very two of them were
murdered and so they went down because
one of them wanted a tummy tuck and you
know my journalist brain was going off
like why are we going to Mexico first
let me tell when you know there's
doctors here in the U.S
um and so that's kind of how I found out
about medical tourism I think medical
tourism is getting popular is just for a
couple reasons for one it's the cost
Effectiveness
um a lot of people travel down to
different countries like Mexico
um because procedures there can
sometimes be less expensive than they
are here in the states and then of
course there is less restrictions in
certain countries so some doctors here
in the states might tell someone oh you
know you're too old or your BMI may be
too high for a certain procedure but a
doctor a foreign doctor might you know
take them and be able to perform the
procedure and then
um especially with the overturning of
bro here recently in a lot of states or
making abortions illegal
um a lot of people are traveling outside
of the country to get procedures like
abortions done in countries where
they're still legal
cosmetic surgeries interestingly make up
only about 13 percent of the total
surgeries that we find that people are
traveling for so it's it's far less than
overall all the surgeries General
surgeries about 30 percent and much less
than Dental which is probably about 50
pharmaceutical we don't have a good
understanding of that but here recently
with the supply of Olympic being
restrained in the United States there
was a study that showed among Canadian
pharmacies that about 10 percent of
their total their total prescriptions
for Olympic were going to American
citizens really depends on the type of
people they're traveling their needs and
also the again the core competence that
exist in that specific location
interestingly Americans have an
interesting view in regards to
International health care and that they
tend to be fairly provincial and they
tend to not believe that there's good
health care outside of the United States
compared to what's here in the United
States and in some cases there may be
some truth to that but there are many
places around the world that are
providing extraordinarily good care
usually at lower prices than not only
what a cash price would be in the United
States but in some cases the price is
lower than what you would pay for your
deductible meaning though even though
you're insured whether you have a health
care product from the exchange or
private insurance you may be paying
thousands of dollars out of pocket for
your deductible and it's actually cost
less than that to get a procedure
internationally and so when you combine
that with a trip you may actually end up
with a vacation and health care for much
less than you would expect
people coming inbound
foreign patients International patients
coming into the United States are tend
to be affluent
it's actually really interesting just
because you wouldn't think that you know
this city in Texas especially because
I'm from Texas I had no clue
um that you know this is where a lot of
foreigners were coming to get procedures
done
Houston has a world-class medical center
Houston is known for two things one of
them is energy and oil and gas and the
other is health care and so Houston has
the largest Medical Center on Earth uh
it is a massive accumulation of very
specialized facilities it's called the
Texas Medical Center
[Music]
one of the things that Houston is doing
in particular is the integration the
Houston and the Texas Medical Center
which is the largest Medical Center on
the face of the Earth has a cluster
approach in layman's terms the Texas map
centers a very defined piece of
geography and within that piece of
geography are massive hospitals you know
Texas Methodist Hospital Memorial
Hermann Hospital and so the hospitals
and practices that are there in the
grounds of the Texas Medical Center
proper are part of this bigger Hospital
systems and they use What's called the
international patient advisory Council
to get together a variety of
organizations from throughout Houston
including the Chambers of Commerce the
airports the local city county state and
federal government the restaurants the
hotels the hospitals they all get
together and what they do is they
coordinate and talk about things for
example Transportation if you're an Arab
patient coming into Houston you're going
to want to know that not only can you
come here and be safe and secure and you
have a good place to stay for you and
your entourage but you also need to know
that you're going to be able to access
halal food a lot of procedures require
patients to stay in close proximity to
their hospitals like this kind of an
extreme example but like the people on
my 600 pound life for example they
oftentimes travel to Houston to get
their procedures done their my gastric
sleeve or gastric bypass and so they
have to stay close to their hospitals or
even stay in the hospitals
um to get that you know the the post-op
work done and so sometimes they have to
like literally uplift their families so
that they can come stay with them for
you know months or weeks or however long
it takes and so that's one reason and
then other procedures like bbls for
example
um and other cosmetic procedures like
the first
week or even a couple days can be a
little brutal in terms of recovery
especially with like you know lymphatic
drains and they have to like sleep or
even sit a certain way and so I can
imagine that
going through that recovery phase is can
be much more beneficial or even
convenient in a place like a house or an
apartment
um rather than like a hotel for example
especially because you have to pay for a
hotel by the night whereas a rental you
can you know oftentimes pay like by uh
by the week or by the month
[Music]
I'm Michelle Kneeland with corporate
Retreats International and we're based
out of Houston Texas we're a corporate
housing company but we specialize in
furnished apartments in the Texas
Medical Center area people seeking
medical treatment find us a number of
ways Word of Mouth maybe from a friend
who came here
Joe's house is a resource that we get a
lot of calls from it's a website and or
a list
that's a resource for specifically
people seeking cancer treatment
so it offers a number of housing options
for people who are receiving cancer
treatment
we also get calls people are referred by
the different hospitals by the social
workers or agencies at the hospitals
they they'll get a list of of housing
options and people also just drive
around and look for something that they
like they'll walk into a Lobby and
they'll be referred to us that way as
well I would say it's on average between
20 and 30 percent at any given time of
our residents are here from outside the
U.S
and they they travel here usually with a
lot of family members so it's more
common that they would be looking for a
two or three bedroom apartment than a
one bedroom
but we see people from all over the
world
typically see that travel great
distances to come see us are people that
have usually had a failed surgery
somewhere else and these people are in
in Desperate shape uh so desperate that
they'll travel you know thousands and
thousands of miles to try to find the
right uh practice or doctor or both to
help them some of the simple things that
it's just easy to overlook so for
instance if somebody has a big revision
spine surgery and they need home health
well Home Health won't respond to a
hotel right so to hook them into the
services that they're likely to need
where you can put them into more of a
home situation with a physical address
so that they can receive that care that
they're going to need after a big
complicated surgery I would say in the
80 to 85 percent range of our of our Rev
and come from people who are here for
medical treatment of some kind and
probably in the 25 range would be
International and that of course changes
all the time because we have people move
in and move out every single day so it's
it's in flux some people stay with us
for six weeks two months six months a
year so that those International numbers
kind of change all the time but that's
probably a pretty pretty accurate
representation of our of our clientele
in places like Houston we typically have
international patients that will come in
they spend a very large amount of money
typically about 10 times as much as what
a tourist would pay in Houston so in
other words a normal tourist coming to
Houston doing most types of tourism
activities they would spend say in the
nature of
maybe three four thousand dollars at the
most probably in the hundreds of dollars
is more average and for medical tourism
the total amount could be tens of
thousands of dollars at least thousands
potentially tens of thousands of dollars
so the the uh the economic impact of
foreign tourists coming into a place
like Houston is tremendous
about six hundred thousand visitors in
Houston came from foreign countries in
2022 alone and out of that six hundred
thousand over twenty thousand of them
came for medical purposes and the
average amount of money being spent by
patients in Houston is thirty four
hundred dollars and that's not including
things like Hotel travel food and other
miscellaneous costs that's just strictly
focusing on inpatient and Outpatient
Care
so interestingly what we've seen around
the world is an increase in affluence
many people have heard about in the
business literature the idea of the
brics which was Brazil Russia India
China those have expanded greatly to
include many countries that are seeing
increases in affluence meaning that
they're the people that are in those
countries have more money than ever
before one of the first things that
people do when they have more money and
also interestingly one of the things
that most immigrants are traveling for
is they're looking for better education
for their children so therefore you see
like educational tourism as it's
sometimes called if you go to most
top-tier business schools around the
world you're going to find that a very
large percentage of them are from
overseas and the reason they travel into
the country is to get access to better
education another thing that people do
as soon as they have more money is they
they want to travel and they want to eat
better and so we see that in terms of
the tourism aspects and then the fourth
if you will leg of the stool or the
chair is health care when people get
more money one of the first things they
want to do is they want to have better
health for themselves and their family
so International tourists coming to the
US for medical tourism
they're more like affluent and they have
more money and more resources to travel
for
um medical purposes especially after the
covid-19 pandemic
[Music]
the pandemic
made basically the entire world sicker
the the more people are sick more people
are ill more people have put off health
care
for too long for years during the
pandemic there's estimates that upwards
of 40 percent of Americans alone gained
on an average of about 15 pounds during
the pandemic there's estimates that 10
percent of British people put off
seeking Cancer Care during the pandemic
all of these issues are leading to the
world being a much sicker Place Plus
many people were sedentary and sat
around and watched Netflix way too much
and snacked on food while during the
pandemic all of this has led to people
needing more Health Care and More
invasive and higher Acuity levels of
Health Care the American Medical
Association is saying that just in the
U.S hall hospitals alone just domestic
patients are seeing overall bills about
10 percent higher than they were before
the pandemic not due to inflation but
due to the Acuity or this their level of
sickness when they they present so more
people are presenting with stage two
cancer when they should have presented
with stage one if they had engaged in
primary care and preventative Services
obviously during the pandemic I think
that our recent experience with the
coronavirus pandemic has really really
puts International Health Care on its
ear obviously there's been a tremendous
amount of regulations and rules about
travel visas and this and that
historically Houston is a natural place
for international patients to come not
only because of our Medical Center and
just our expertise in healthcare in
general but also geographically Central
America South America we see a lot of
people from the Middle East because of
our ties with oil and gas and so we see
a large number of patients within our
practice every year we have Departments
of individuals that are that are geared
towards helping those people with some
of the unique challenges that they face
as they seek Health Care yeah I mean
most of it is just logistical
um you know the the care of the
international patient is challenging for
a lot of reasons as a surgeon the
biggest reason that that I come into
grips with is the support system for the
person and so for instance if I was to
operate on you and you were from Houston
the surrounding area that once we got
done with you and we were to send you
home you'd have the support of your
family and all those types of things and
so our biggest emphasis on caring for
international folks is understanding the
fact that they don't have that support
system around there and and people with
very simple problems uh rarely travel a
thousand or more miles to get that
simple problem carried for and so our
entire focus is that of of just helping
the individual with some type of support
structure
so people when they first call us are
usually
extremely under a lot of stress
sometimes I just found out they have
this diagnosis or their family member
does and they're going to be traveling
from across the world or across the
country some long distance they've not
been to Houston maybe and they they
really have no idea that this is all
very stressful and very unknown
um so
what's really amazing is when I do get
the chance to tour someone or even just
really get to narrow down what they want
even over the phone and help them find
what's a good fit you can just hear
relief in their voice see it on their
face it's such an important thing for
people to say Okay I I know where I'm
going to stay when I'm here and I like
that at least I know I'm going to be
going through a really tough time and I
don't know what that's going to look
like for me but at least I'm going to be
in a comfortable place where I'm going
to feel safe
where I can relax and rest and recover
it is really tough because it's not like
we what we do is just just lease
Apartments just rent apartments to
people I mean it's very personal
um
you know people call you crying there's
there's really good stories of really
good success stories a lot of Happy
Endings and then there's there's some
really tough things that happen as well
so
it's hard because we aren't like a
non-profit we're running a business but
we have to have empathy for all of our
customers
thank you
I'll give you some evidence to show how
big medical tourism is into the United
States
back in the Obama Administration I think
it was the end of those first term they
decided to give a grant for establishing
a group it's called you Skip and it's a
group of the best what most well-known
academic medical centers in the United
States so that they could get together
and promote themselves and promote
Health Care in the United States so it
was identified again under the Obama
Administration as being one of the
up-and-coming
revenue streams for the United States in
terms of how large it is just here in
Houston alone we know it's hundreds of
millions of dollars so across the United
States there is estimates to say that
potentially with all the people coming
in and all the locations it it may
potentially reach upwards of a billion
dollars in total revenue coming from
foreign patients now there's some
distinctions in that is that all Health
Care Revenue probably not that probably
includes both flights hotels
Transportation food tourism there's a
variety of aspects that go into medical
tourism but overall we know that it's a
significant driver of Revenue in several
places throughout the United States so
this is leading to again
unhealthy populations greater
utilization put off health care for a
long time it's kind of like a if you
will a perfect storm for medical tourism
and so locations like Houston which
already see a large number of foreign
Nationals it's going to be a boom for
them and don't forget we're also seeing
increasing population growth in places
like Latin America one of the number one
locations for foreign Nationals coming
into Houston we're seeing population
growth in places like Asia which was
sending a lot of medical tourists into
the United States prior to the pandemic
so there's there's a lot of if you will
upward pressures or upward
opportunities for medical tourism to
grow and my belief is it's going to grow
at at least a double digit rate going
forward historically both in to and out
of the United States we've seen about 10
15 percent growth rates I expect that to
continue in the near future
[Music]